Allah speaks about the enemy, and Allah
says those disbelievers are protectors
of one another. They
will protect each other. If you are not
going to protect each other as well,
there will be chaos and corruption on
earth. Exactly, and I agree with him.
Like when it comes to people saying,
"Oh, the Shias or this." How How
disgusting can you be? 160 plus girls
were massacred.
I want to invite you to add something
[music] powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah
list. We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn wudu, how to pray, how to recite
Surah Al-Fatiha, every Fajr, Zuhr, Asr,
Maghrib,
>> Isha, Tahajjud,
>> Tarawih, every prayer for the rest of
their lives, you share in the reward.
[music]
>> When they teach their children, and
their children's children,
the reward continues for you. For just
100 pounds, you can help teach 20 to 60
people like me learn salah. Donate today
and earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. So, I came across a post Well,
I didn't come across it. Rizwan came
across it. My
Bengali friend here, he's a very good
Bengali guy. I love the Bengali people.
Balani Balasee Cinefun.
Moving on swiftly. Brothers and sisters,
jokes aside, alhamdulillah. Mufti Menk
made a post. Now, this I've seen a lot
of people attacking him, subhanallah.
I'm just trying to understand
where people's frustrations are coming
from, okay? Now, sometimes, brothers and
sisters, we want people to be as as
active as us. Some of us have certain
standards, okay? And I understand now.
People were like, "Oh, Mufti Menk
doesn't speak about the Gaza situation."
I'm going to show you videos where Mufti
has actively Mufti Menk has actively
spoken about now. Am I Mufti Menk's
cousin, uncle? No. He's another
believer. I have no loyalty to him, to
anybody for that matter.
With all due respect, okay. Okay, guys.
So, let me make that clear. I have no
loyalty. I don't have any bonus that I
give Mufti Menk or any
this or clout or that whatever it's for
that matter. I'm just genuinely saying
brothers and sisters that we have to be
just sometimes. Now here is what he
posted. "When you don't know exactly
what's going on, it's best not to say
the wrong thing. Let those with a deeper
understanding in that matter say what
needs to be said. The prophetic teaching
to those who believe in the day of
reckoning is utter what's upright or
remain silent." Now Dan Bilzerian
commented to that, but you know it's
actually quite profound because if you
read this nasiha he's saying, people
started thinking this is talking about
Iran and they're saying don't talk about
Iran or Sudan or Gaza or whatever is
going on. He didn't say that guys. Let's
be just here. And not only that, isn't
it ironic that he's saying when you
don't know exactly what's going on.
Look, reading his comment, if you don't
know what's going on in his comment and
what he's trying to say, look at the
irony. It's best not to say the wrong
thing.
I mean come on, you can't make that up.
The guy's nasiha, which is about
something else generic, applies to his
own post which is for me all of us, but
when we're reading this, when you don't
know exactly what's going on, his tweet,
we don't know what it's about. Okay,
don't jump to assumption. It's best not
to say the wrong thing. Meaning, don't
look, you don't know what his post is
around about what's going on in Mufti
Menk's mind and don't say the wrong
thing by judging and say "Ah, he's
telling us to be quiet about Iran or
Iran or whatever it is that matter."
Let those with a deeper understanding in
that matter say what needs to be said.
So it could apply here that he's talking
about something completely different and
it's going to apply for marriage.
This could apply to marriage. You're
having an issue or somebody out there
outside is observing. Don't get
involved. You don't know what's going
on. Let the people in the field or
whatever. This can be about business.
This can be about friendship. This can
be about the day of judgment. This can
be about so many stuff. This can be
about scholarly fatwa stuff. But no, the
the prophet's teaching is to those who
believe in the day of reckoning is to
utter what's upright or remain silent.
Now how could you twist that? And this
is what happens guys when people twist
things. Now Dan Bilzerian came along and
said or you could locate your
boos and speak up about the Jewish
supremacy problem plague plaguing your
people."
Now, again,
this is not fair. Why? Because number
one,
he doesn't know what's going on or what
he's talking about. He's probably under
the assumption again cuz sometimes we
have preconceived notions.
Argument sake, I'm I had an argument
with my friend.
Someone comes and says something and I
lash at him because I'm in the zone of
argument and frustration and and
defensiveness. Somebody comes and says
something like, um
"Bro, are you okay?" And I'm like, "Oh,
yeah, I'm okay, but why are you talking
to me like that?" "Bro, I just asked if
you're okay." This is what he's talking
about. Now, for those who are like, "Oh,
no, but Mufti Menk doesn't talk about
this and that." Guys, look, I can show
you videos. I'll show you a video right
now of subhanallah him talking about
Iran and talking about Gaza.
Subhanallah, let's let's watch it for
ourselves. Today,
while Gaza is being bombed and Iran is
being bombed, it hurts us. It really
hurts us as an ummah.
But, we find ourselves fragmented to the
degree that some might even say, "Well,
it's okay. You know, those guys are like
this and those guys are like that."
Well, I have to be like
That's not good enough.
Because
in no time, it will come to you and I.
And then others will say the same thing.
That who are they? What are they going
to do? Oh, they deserve it. I've heard
people say they deserve it. How dare we
say they deserve it?
We are supposed to be from among those
who care for each other no matter what.
I might have differences with you. I
might have had a little squabble with
you, but trust me,
when push comes to shove, I should stand
up for you.
We are closer than anything else. We are
members of an ummah. And the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam has warned us
about this. In fact, the Quran says,
>> Allah speaks about the enemy.
And Allah says, "Those disbelievers are
protectors of one another."
They will protect each other.
If you are not going to protect each
other as well,
there will be chaos and corruption on
earth in a very great way. And that's
what we're witnessing. Had we stood up
for one another, if we were all there
for one another, if we were genuine
towards one another, we would not have
witnessed the chaos we are witnessing
today. Exactly, and I agree with him.
Like when it comes to people saying,
"Oh, they're Shias or this." How How
disgusting can you be?
160-plus girls were massacred.
Shia, what is wrong with you? Some
weird, deranged people who are Sunni,
deranged, happy that Shias are being
massacred. Are you Okay in the head?
Even less of us. We know what Iran did
in Syria. Are they our teachers? No.
Why do you want the same to them? What's
the difference between you and a
Zionist?
This is number one. And number two, for
example, another video where he's where
he speaks about Gaza. Look at what
Israel is doing to the Palestinians.
Every day, thousands of people are being
affected, either killed or driven out of
their homes. Now, millions are displaced
and thousands have been killed in in a
style as though they're enjoying doing
what they're doing.
Do you think that Allah's going to let
it go?
Do we not want to see justice?
We want to see justice. Will that
justice happen in this world in my life?
Inshallah, but maybe it might not happen
the way we want it to happen, but Allah
says, "Leave it to me."
That doesn't mean don't do anything
about it. I'm speaking about it right
now.
Right?
But what it does mean
is that they will pay the heaviest price
on the day of Qiyamah, the day of
judgement, to say the least. Okay, good.
So, for those like I said to you before,
people are coming and saying, you know,
he doesn't talk about this, he doesn't
talk about that. Yes, he does. Now, can
you argue and say he should be a bit
more vocal, a bit more out there, maybe
like Imam Omar Suleiman, he's like, you
know, he's on the ground, etc. Okay. We
Look, I respect that. If you come and
say, he should be a little bit Look, I
understand. But you cannot come and take
someone and this Leave all the good he's
done and write him off instantly. If he
said nothing about Gaza or the conflict
or whatever it is, then you can say, you
know what, hold on a second. Whoa, hold
on a second. Nothing?
You don't say nothing?
I think that's when we can say we can
draw the line. Cuz when it comes to
Gaza, we have to draw that line. Whoever
it is, I don't care wherever that is,
Subhanallah for that matter. So, what
I'm just saying is this, guys. We need
to sometimes not read into stuff because
people are taking this and it's a
slander.
I say something, you take it out of
context, and then you start slandering
me and calling me names when I didn't
even say that or I was talking about
something completely different. The
timing could be wrong. You can say the
timing is wrong, but at least where is
good assumptions? Like at least if you
know someone to known to be doing good,
why can't you just assume the best? Why
is it one thing and
that's it. That's all I wanted to say,
inshallah. And I'm Palestinian. Um
there's nothing else to be said. We
understand you speak about again.
There's a lot of stuff that we say, I'll
be honest with you, that it's it's it's
I'll be honest with you, it's
genuine anti-semitism. I'm not talking
about I'm a Muslim. I get anti-semitism.
But to blame Jews for everything and
Jews Jews like Jews I'm so sorry. We
can't We can't come and say every single
Jew then what's the difference between
them and us? Every single Muslim a
terrorist.
That's why I don't understand,
inshallah. This is Ramadan, let's watch
what we say like with our tongues
because the Prophet said, if you promise
me two things, what what's between your
lips and what's between your legs, I
will promise you Jannah. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Takbir!
Allahu Akbar. This is the new sadaqah
jariyah in town. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us in the Quran A man
pleading with Allah to send him back so
he could give sadaqah. Why sadaqah?
Because he knows the weight of sadaqah.
Just 100 pounds. You can help teach 20
to 60 people to learn
>> how to perform salah, recite Surah
Fatiha, and make wudu. Click the link
and donate now.